Justice doesn't look like it's coming  anytime soon we saw today he was  speaking at the New York Times Summit it  wasn't a very serious situation at all  we could see he lied he made some jokes  he received a round of applause  afterwards and also you just have to  look at the people that are involved  with FTX I mean sambang mccreed was one  of the second largest donors to  President Biden's campaign he had the  likes of Bill Clinton and Tony Blair  speaking his conference down in the  Bahamas so I'm not feeling very  confident that he will see the true  weight of the law even the New York  Times of creating all these puff pieces  about him Forbes were glorifying him  it's very bizarre and unfortunately I  don't think he's gonna seek real Justice